في الكويت فيديو لتكريم طالبات ارتدينا
الحجاب اثار حاله كبيره من الجدل مقطع
الفيديو مدته 30 ثانيه شاهده الملايين
ومباشره بعد انتشار هذا الفيديو اشتعلت
التعليقات بين مرحب
ومنتقد الفعل المعترضون مشاهدينا ومنهم
جمعيات مدنيه اعتبروا ان تكريم الطالبات
بسبب حجابهم انما هو تمييز في الطفوله بل
وصل البعض لوصفه بغسيل المخ على الجانب
الاخر هناك من استنكر هذه الهجمه ضد
المدرسه ومديرتها وقالوا انها مربيه فاضله
وتسعى لغرس الاخلاق الحميده والايجابيه
وانما حدث ليس الا مجرد تكريم
[موسيقى]
في حجاب الا جمالا وجمالا لم ينقصني مرحا
لربي طاعه
هذه انا
الذي اكت
ينضم اذا الينا من الكويت الكاتب الصحفي
علي خاجه علي صبحك الله بالخير
صبحك الله بالنور يا حبيبي ليش هالجدل
الدائر بالكويت ليش دائما الكويتين عندهم
مشاكل بين مؤيد
ومعارض يعني مدرسه ومديره مدرسه كرم
الطالباتها ليش هذا الجدل
الجدل طبيعي كويتيه طبيعي كويتيه طبعا في
اي قضيه سواء كانت هذه القضيه او غيرها من
قضايا لكن احنا نتكلم اليوم ولابد انه
نشدد ان ما قامت به المدرسه بكل تاكيد هو
بحسن نيه بكل تاكيد هو عمل يسعون من خلاله
الى الى امر يعتقدون ان ان جيد يعتقدون
انه محبب ويجب ان يتم اتخاذه الهاجس او
المشكله اللي احنا نشوفها ان هذا الاقحام
خصوصا في مرحله ابتدائيه احنا نتكلم عن
مرحله اكبر طالبه عمرها 11 سنه امور غير
اكاديميه هذه مو متعلقه بامور اكاديميه
وهذه امور
متعلقه بمظهر
لهذه الطالبه او للفتيات فهذا المظهر
ومحاوله ان تمييز
حجابات عن غيرهم نعتقد او ماني متكلم صيغه
الجمع اعتقد انه ما هو مناسب في المدرسه
لانه راح يعطي انطباع وراح يعطي احساس فيه
بقيه طالبات
اعتراض على تكريم فتيات بهذا شكل البعض
قال بانه يعني هو ليس فقط تمييز ضد
الطالبات غير المحجبات هو قد يكون هل هذا
حقيقي يعني يثير القلق بانه قد يكون طريقه
لوضع الضغط على الطالبات غير المحجبات لكي
يتحجبن يعني بالتاكيد بالتاكيد هذا قد
يكون احد احد
الحواجز والمخاوف اول شيء احنا في مدرسه
احنا المدرسه هذا مكان اكاديمي لا باس من
تكريم الفائقات في مجالات الدراسه
والمجالات الاكاديميه والمجالات الانشطه
اللي في المدرسه هذا طبعا لا باس اسم
النبل هو تعزيز لدورهم الاكاديمي والتفوق
في هذه المجالات لكن لما احنا نتكلم
وتحديدا في هذه المرحله ان التكريم على
اساس ظاهري على اساس شكلي قد يؤثر بشكل او
باخر على بقيه طالبات خصوصا
يعني بطالبات متحجبات ويعني
كرموهم المدرسه
وزاره التربيه ويريدون اختطاف البلد حتى
وصلت الى هذه بفعل
مديره مدرسه كرم الطالبات هل يستحق هذا
الموضوع
يمكن موضوع الاسلاميين ويحاولون او
التيارات التيارات الاسلام السياسي
يحاولون الاختطاف البلد واسلمت التعليم
وغيره هذا هذا امر اخر في معزل عن ما قامت
فيه هذه المدرسه ما اعتقد انه هناك ارتباط
هي مبادره مثل ما قلت في بدايه كلامي هي
مبادره من
مسؤوله تربويه تعتقد ان هذه مبادره جيده
انا اعتقد العكس انا اعتقد ان ماي مبادره
جيده بحيث انها لا ترتكز على جانب اكاديمي
يعني مو مؤامره ترتكز على
استبعد انها تكون مؤامره المؤامره ترى
بالمناسبه هناك وايد عناصر المؤامره بس
استبعد ان هذا يكون استاذ علي كلمه السر
هي التي ذكرتها في البدايه بانه هذا
التكريم يعني كان بمبادره من المدرسه
وبحسن
نيه بغض النظر عن الجدل وما له وما عليه
يعني اذا تكررت هذا اللي اعتبره طيب شكرا
جزيلا
وهذه طبعا الراي المعارض للراي اللي يشوف
ان التكريم ما في شيء ويجب ان يعزز خلني
نعكس الايه خل نحاول نقول انه في مدرسه في
احدى الدول ما ما تكون دوله الكويت في
احدى الدول تكرم غير المحجبات
احنا راح نعترض لكن اللي يكرم غير
المحجبات هل راح يطالب بالحريات وعدم
التمييز والجزئيه الاخيره قانون حمايه طفل
واضح لا يجوز التمييز وهذا قانون اقر
بالاجماع في دوله الكويت لا يجوز التمييز
وفيه الاهم من هيك لا اكرهها في الدين
كمان يعني هو يجب اي خطوه
التحجب لازم تكون عن اقتناع شكرا جزيلا لك
الصحه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات